what's going on guys welcome back we're
GQ recommends and today we're going to
be talking about three coats to get you
through the winter
[Music]
there were a lot of coats that we could
have talked about so many goats I mean
we could have talked about leather coats
could have talked about like a pea coat
or a really thick like shearling coat
like Bane level yeah yeah Bane level we
wanted to keep it to tighter list
something that's going to work for a lot
of people I also think that they happen
to be like some of the most versatile
and each one speaks to a very different
type of style so out of all the fresh
fly and totally rad coats out there
we're only going to be talking about
three categories today and they are the
puffer the top goat and wait for it the
fleece let's get into it
the puffer jacket
first off we wanted to start with the
puffer jacket it's pretty essential it
comes in a lot of different different
styles different levels of warmth but we
think that it can work in any climate it
doesn't have to be in New York and can
be somewhere milder I feel like the the
archetypical puffer jacket is like that
longer cinched at the waist Expedition
parka that like the Explorers wore when
they actually had to really worry about
staying warm and that was stuffed with
the same sort of filling or a synthetic
version of it that you're going to find
in one of these today yeah totally I
mean it's basically like wearing a duvet
totally like with sleeves and a zipper
so Gerald the the puffer that we picked
today we picked for a very specific
reason and not only because of its
ubiquity it's such a hot jacket right
now but it's the north Face's nupsy
jacket and it's not just any nopsy it's
in fact the Retro version the one based
on the jacket The North Face released in
the 90s which means that it's a little
bit more cropped and way more epoxy than
a lot of other puffers on the market but
we think that looks kind of cool because
it helps balance out like The baggier
Wider pants that we're seeing now and
the sturdier kicking boots kind of
creates this cohesive element to your
winter outfit so I think it would be
hard to do with a puffer that's sort of
Slimmer and longer yeah totally it's
trendy but also a very classic cut
really if you go back to say uh when the
puffer jacket was first invented by
Eddie Bauer it was a shorter style you
would see Silhouettes like this all the
time in like the 50s and 60s and then
Nipsey in particular is like about as
iconically New York as Timberlands or
like a fitted Yankees hat it just works
on the East Coast this jacket uh can
also pack into itself which is a nice
feature because I I feel like a lot of
the times I go out and it's cold and
then all of a sudden I'm walking like
five minutes and I'm a little too warm
or you look at the weather and it's not
what it says and you're like I really
don't need this you can just pack it
down and zip it up and like throw it in
your bag yeah you can't do that with
with a lot of coats you can't do that
with like a top coat or like a pea coat
you're just stuck with it like we said
there are a lot of different versions of
puffer jackets
um and if you really want to go for it
you want something that's gonna stand
out and get you some
maybe some daps maybe some uh head turns
the uh and wander Diamond Stitch down
jacket is insane it's definitely well
equipped to take on whatever winter
you're experiencing but
I mean to be honest I'm never gonna go
through
that harsh of the winter I just want to
wear it because it's so sick it just
looks sick and like you know that it's
crafted from the highest quality
materials in Japan and wander
specializes in like very Outdoors
friendly gorp Wares that'll make look
like you're ready to hike up the highest
treacherous amount of whatever Mountain
you're trying to scale even if you're
just hightailing it to the subway it's a
dope jacket yeah it's sick there's a
reason why when you think of winter
jackets and coats you probably think of
the puffer it's because it's the one
that's going to get the job done no
matter what the weather entails and if
your primary concern is purely staying
warm it's the jacket you want to get
foreign
[Music]
so this next coat is one of my favorites
it's from a brand called The Bone factor
it's called their granddad jacket
Granddad coat one of those they have
this every season and it like almost I
think almost every season it sells out
even as like you know it's a it's a
hefty price point it's really good it's
probably my favorite one that we're
talking about today I think the details
are really spot on in terms of like the
fabric and the fit right and in general
The Styling opportunities here it feels
like really cinematic like this is like
some oh yeah Humphrey Bogart Cary Grant
yeah it's it's beautiful I mean
I think this code really embodies the
top coat category top cuts are long
they're usually made of like wool are
meant to go over maybe a lighter jacket
or even just a sweater they can be
really rakish loosh a little dressy but
you definitely don't have to wear it
like that you can easily wear it over a
hoodie or you know just a thrash t-shirt
if it's not
it's not that cold outside I guess
that's what I like most about this genre
of code like because they feel for lack
of a better word so rich they're gonna
make everything else you're wearing look
exponentially more pulled together oh
totally I mean especially in winter you
know you don't have the luxury of being
able to show off like as much of your
jewelry so it's really about the outer
layer and this is like it's a statement
but it's not it's not super loud it's
not super garish it's very classic it's
going to work for you
you know 10 years 20 years 50 years from
now yeah when I think of people who wear
the top coat particularly well
especially nowadays I think of Jonah
Hill a lot I think he's able to blend
his sort of like skate inflected Art
Gallery kid attitude with these more
statement like designer outerwear pieces
and then dress them down with like a
hoodie and a pair of like scuffed Adidas
which I think speaks to the top coats
versatility and its ability like we said
to make everything you're wearing look
more put together by default yeah Jonah
Hill's a really good one I tend to think
home alone and Home Alone 2 the wet
Bandits I mean I I feel like it's maybe
been talked to death but like
that's kind of what I'm going for when
I'm wearing a top coat honestly yeah you
want like the precariously perched knit
beanie yeah like a knit beanie maybe big
scarf and like uh knit gloves that's
great and amazing and awesome as this
coat is if you don't want to spend quite
that much the Knickerbocker Charlie top
coat is a great option that one actually
feels more wet Bandit like which which I
really love I actually have like a very
similar for I have damn I have I have a
few I have a few very similar versions
to this it's more of a single breasted
uh code it doesn't have a belt it's a
little more clean I would say but still
a classic looking coat you can
definitely find vintage versions that
I'm sure that you know that those
vintage versions were on their mood
boards or something the most appealing
component of a top goat to me is like
the serious Geezer energy that comes
along with it Menswear at large is like
cottoning on to the fact that old dudes
are like some of the best dressed people
on the planet and they've had these
things for years and wear them routinely
every year for months on end if you're
looking for a coat that sort of
harnesses that old school Hollywood
energy the top coat is the one you want
to get
[Music]
fleece jacket
the third essential coat that we're
going to be talking about today to help
you survive the winter is actually not a
coat at all it's a jacket and it's a
jacket that you're probably familiar
with because they're super hot right now
and almost everyone has one it's the
fleece jacket the way I would probably
wear this is under another coat like
either the top coat that we just talked
about or the puffer that we mentioned
earlier on but if you're somewhere not
on the east coast and are enjoying
blessedly more friendly temperatures you
could probably wear a fleece as a
standalone layer and that would be the
only jacket you need when the
temperature starts to dip the fleece
jacket might not sound like a winter
coat but like you said it depends where
you are I think uh for certain cities
this is a winter jacket the one we want
to really highlight for this is the
Patagonia retro X fleece jacket like the
nupsy earlier that we talked about it is
a retrode version of a fleece jacket
that Patagonia used to make like in the
80s early 90s those have been really hot
with like vintage collectors and can
fetch a pretty high price point so it's
great that you can just find one brand
new and you don't have to hunt for them
so it's got contrasting panels at the
chest pocket and the collar for a little
bit more durability it's also got
elastic at the cuffs and at the Hem to
kind of cinch it up and keep the wind
out and this I mean dude the fleece on
this it's what people would refer to as
a deep pile fleece if you think about
like a rug like a low pile like deep
yeah this should go Steve I'm crying
damn bro fleece which is a fabric that's
super cozy and that you're probably
familiar with is like mostly prized for
how comfortable it is and how soft and
fuzzy
um but now we're seeing a lot of really
high-end and really cool Buzzy brands
also making fleece like a main stay of
their collections there are a ton of
luxury Brands making fleece jackets
Marnie
JW Anderson like
there's not a brand that isn't making a
police jacket it's almost like every
brand has their own Gene you know so one
of our favorite Lux versions of a fleece
jacket comes from 4S designs if you want
something a little crazier you know with
the same texture and comfort and warmth
this guy is pretty wild
um fun fact you can have like crazy
prints with uh with fleece it's not
really yeah no it seems like that's
something that Brands didn't know you
could do until like the last few years
and like suddenly there's been an
explosion of Brands across the price
Spectrum doing up fleece and like the
wildest patterns you can imagine the
cool thing about fleece these days is
that like it's not only incorporated
into the classic silhouette that you see
here like 4S designs for example uses
this same pattern and the same material
but does it up in like a trucker jacket
silhouette with a trim leather collar
which is also a really cool way to
incorporate fleece into your outfits
without feeling like you're wearing the
more conventional fleece style totally
there I mean you brought a great Point
how there's another version of this in a
trucker style I've seen some in chore
codes or even uh in like a top coat yeah
like just you know basically head to toe
fleece so the fleece jacket is more of
the material but you know the Patagonia
is sort of the archetype of the fleece
jacket and people are using the material
in all kinds of different ways in a ton
of different silhouettes
foreign
[Music]
if you're looking to expand your
outerwear repertoire slightly and you
don't want to go too overboard if you're
trying to condense it into just three
essential styles that you want to wear a
ton throughout the rest of your life
start here the puffer the fleece and the
top goat any variation of those will
keep you toasty and keep you looking and
feeling your best even during the dog
days of the coldest months of the year
Well sent agreed